hello everyone we have an amazing game
played in round five of the 2017 World
Cup between Magnus Carlsen and Busey on
Z and I really enjoyed this game because
well one player grabs a pawn and the
other one sacrifices a piece and
punishes him old-school style and the
peace sacrifice isn't really justified
as well people who use engines would say
but you know Carlson didn't really make
any bad moves it's just that well move
after move boos young he got too much
out of the position and well in the end
finished with the brilliancy so let's
see this wonderful game Carson is white
and the yangzi is black we have E 4 E 5
Bishop to c4 Carlsen goes for the Bishop
opening nice to f6 we have d3 Knight to
c6 and now Knight to f3 transposing to
an Italian game we have Bishop to e7
cross and castles black castles and now
Bishop to b3 we have b6 c3 I'm making
room for that Bishop and c2 we have
Bishop to e6 and now rook to e1 and
Queen to d7
we have Knight B to d2 rook a to b8 and
Bishop to see - and here as Young's
immediately pushes d5 as now Carson
allowed it since the bishop is no longer
controlling that square we have h3 by
Carlson and h6 and now we have a capture
Sun d5 Knight captures on d5 and it
seems like Carlson is winning a pawn
here which he is actually although black
does get an active play for this across
him plays Knight captures on e5 we have
night chapters on e5 rook captures on e5
and now rook to d6 something like a
marshal marshal theme rook back to e1
and now of course Yangtze goes for goes
for it he plays Bishop captures on h3
and well the best thing to do here is to
actually capture the bishop so Carlsen
does it to G captures on h3 and we have
kicker Queen captures on h3 so Magnus is
up a piece but he does have to defend
correctly he plays Knight to f1 which is
a an excellent move
rugby to e8 and nach osten plays d4 also
an excellent move we all know that it's
very hard to attack Magnus Carlsen and
here black plays f5 and this is well
this isn't the greatest of moves but
it's it's the the best human move and
well we have Bishop to b3 by Carson now
painting that night we have seen c6 and
f4 and we have a kink to h7 here
probably this was probably the less the
moment where or Collison should have
played rook to e2 maybe to try and hold
this but he decided to play Bishop
captures on d5 we have C capture 75 and
now he played rook to e3 and here black
simply gets too much for the initiative
he plays rook captures any 3 we have
Bishop captures on e3 and now he pushes
g5 and it's it's extremely hard to play
this for white cross and is still up a
piece but this rook on a one will never
see the light of day
he tries pink to f2 he wants to get his
King to the Queen side as soon as
possible but we have G captures on f4
and well if Carson would try and save
this bishop somehow for example if he
played Bishop to d2 Queen to h4 we have
King to f3 and now Rock the g8 and if
Carson would try to run with the king
for example King - E - he gets made it
with f4 check and now if King goes to d3
simply Queen to e4 is checkmate and if
King captures then simply Queen to e4
check King you have to and that rope to
g2 is checkmate and pretty much anymore
cross mix will end in checkmate
so after this G G captors on f4 a
constant right Queen to f3 he wants to
give back the piece you know to survive
we have F captures and III would check
Knight captures and now Quinta H to
check and well Carlsen can obviously
move the King but he can also block with
the Queen and if he played something
like Queen - G - this loses the Queen to
h4 check and after something like King
to e2 simply
four wins four black if no Knight moves
f3 is coming so this is very deadly so
after a queen to h2 cross and tried King
to f1 now we have worked the g8
threatening rook to g1 checkmate
so Causton plays Queen captures on f5
checking the black king we're up to g6
we have King to e1 he is still trying to
run away with the king
we have h5 king to d1 King to h6 night
to c2h4 nights to e1 and now there seems
to be no more threats here on the last
rank for Carlsen
but we have h3 and this pawn is becoming
a very dangerous pass pawn we have
Knight to f3 by Carson attacking that
Queen on h2 we have Queen to g2 night to
e1 now attacking the Queen again and now
the finishing blow by young he plays
Queen to g4 with check and this is
deadly Carson has to accept the Queen
Queen Katherine g4 we have rook captures
on g4 here at Carlson plays Knight to f3
sort of to prevent black from playing h2
but here comes a crushing blow rope the
g1 check and there is no more moves for
calls and unfortunately if he moves the
king he loses the rook and if he accepts
this then simply h2 wins the game
whatever white I mean costs in place if
this Knight moves then simply h1 Queen
and well there is no no no way to stop
this even if even if King to d2 of
course black isn't gonna capture the
night he is just gonna grab the Queen
here and this is winning full time for
for black so yeah an amazing game and
yeah I always say if you're gonna defeat
the world champion you know do it do it
with style and definitely booze young
she does it with style so yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank I would like to
thank Norman Hardin for your
contribution to my channel I really
appreciate it thank a lot and yeah as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon